foreign
[Music]
ER again it must be one in battle
instead of Simply sitting the one minute
and 50 seconds of previously awning for
being one minute and 50 seconds of
previously awning I'd like to send it
for being the most contextually spoilery
previously awning we've seen to date if
this had included a sad Droid a Back to
the Future trailer and a saxaboom
rendition of about damn time we wouldn't
have needed to watch the episode at all
also one minute and 50 seconds of
previously awning transporting a fish in
a champagne Coop instead of a flute or
the much more appropriate Bordeaux glass
not giving us an explanation as to why
the captain's the only one that gets a
tank and the rest of these fish holes
just have to be dry you see we were
already hired by a certain mon calamari
Viceroy I apologize if we've seen this
at some point in the past but calling
your obviously piscene flavored species
calamari I can't destroy everything I've
built for a childish fling is that all
this was to you
that's what I meant when did this become
the CW's Mandalorian they've taken
control of the ship I got
right Amanda and Beau passively let the
episode turn into a side quest this is
interesting careful with your exuberant
adjectives there Mando a two minute
recap followed by three minutes of
calamore does not an interesting episode
make welcome to classier15 making your
planet sound like a prescription
strength hemorrhoid cream please proceed
to your hyperloop pod Disney bet hard on
the monorail and lost so now it's
shifting gear so it can cash in on all
the hyperloop hype from 10 years ago
please do not attempt to leave the
vehicle this is not a request
we're going to learn a lot about how
much of a paradise this world is but
somehow no one's ever voted against the
Whiplash inducing dramatic timing of
these hyperloops come everyone special
guests
mandalorians listen I love lizzo and
Jack Black but whenever Star Wars does
these type of cameos it's like they're
pulling the curtain back on the whole
production to say hey look who it is
takes me out of the story every time I
hope you like secretions quickly With
Sips secretions Plaza suffered greatly
under Imperial rule my husband came here
as part of his Rehabilitation okay let
me get this straight Captain Jack here
worked for the Empire and is a
rehabilitation Penance was sent to a
planet abused by said Empire where he
managed to marry his way into the royal
family and be an elected leader how many
war criminals do you know that were
given their own [__] planet to rule
perhaps hold the baby please lizzo
breaks character and they just decide to
keep it in the episode he doesn't take
kindly to strangers saying this instead
of this baby might be able to kill you
with its mind listener seems confused
about what grogu's supposed to be
sometimes he's a baby sometimes he's a
Jedi and other times he's just a puppy
we held direct Democratic elections for
the first time in our history we have
both Royals and elected leaders yeah but
earlier the automated thing he said
15 the outer rims only remaining direct
democracy and if you're electing
representatives then that's not a direct
democracy that's a representative
democracy with direct democracy
institutions see Mom I told you YouTube
wouldn't be a total waste of my college
degree are you proud yet respectfully
what does this have to do with us Katie
sackhoff's question to the writers about
why the characters are even in this
situation somehow makes it into the
episode The Mandalorian Garrison outside
your city walls can make quick work of
your battle droids our Charter forbids
any standing army from entering our city
but somehow that that same Charter is
totally fine with an Imperial cruiser
complete with shuttles camping up just
outside of the city on a [__]
technicality was to stop them from
hiring more mercenaries and building an
army that way sure this keeps the
citizens of plesier 15 safe but it
doesn't do much to prevent that pesky
Imperial tendency to dominate the Galaxy
the people have voted we are a
pluralistic society you are mandalorians
weaponry and armor are intrinsic to your
culture are they not I don't think
you're using pluralism in the way that
you think you are yes being pluralistic
means that you're accepting of a variety
of political and cultural ideologies and
even incorporate them into your system
of ruling but you don't have to be
pluralistic to allow visitors from other
cultures this is like bragging that
you're an all-you-can-eat buffet and
therefore the only type of restaurant
that allows people to bring in their own
food it might be true but it has nothing
to do with the buffet I also might be
hungry also I'm fine with exploiting
loopholes but this loophole applies just
as much to ax's mandalorians as it does
to Bow and den here I see no reason why
you couldn't have asked them to clear
the Droid problem as mandalorians in
exchange for the defense contract Isaiah
15 would formally recognize Mandalore as
a sovereign system and petition the new
Republic to recognize it as such you
mean the random planet that happened to
have hired the mandalorians that dinenbo
need to find also just happens to be in
a position to help them complete their
mission to unite Mandalore what luck the
mercenary Captain acts wolves indicated
that he split from you because you had
designs on ruling Mandalore once again
why the [__] did that come up why would
ax be chatting about the life goals of
his predecessor with a complete stranger
that shouldn't give a [__] those plans
have been abandoned the office stands
nonetheless dude she just said those
planes have been abandoned why are you
standing by this as an offer instead of
cash he had me at battle droids and you
lost me at the Jerry Maguire reference
these Droids were all reprogrammed to
serve as a community Great Scott this is
how we get Doc Brown in Star Wars I mean
it's about damn time but in a minute
I'ma need a explanation for that Mando
cameos feeling foresee why not turn them
all off let's finish this voting against
any Interruption and Droid Services
reminding me that we live in a world
where I can't sin this vote for being
unbelievable and stupid
Ugg nuts
excitement I am crazy I knew it I once
had to re-record a whole video because I
randomly started calling her Bo Katan
instead of Boca tan than the other
characters in the show started calling
her bogoton so I figured maybe it is Bo
Katan but I mean she definitely says
Boca tan here and she should be the one
that knows right so why do people keep
saying Bo Katan I mean Katan tanton we
were sent on behalf of the duchess and
Captain Bombardier to help you with your
Droid problem Amanda let's go Katan fail
multiple times in communicating with the
ugnots instead of speaking up first or
telling her I spent time with hug nuts
there's a particular way to communicate
with them for this episode The Writers
decided to make Dan a real man dick
Lorien we were engaged to hunt down and
eliminate the malfunctioning droids
there are no such droids these aren't
the droids you're looking for in a Star
Wars story cliche they've indicated that
there's a likelihood that the next event
will be at the loading docks what the
hell are they basing that on forget that
they can track the malfunctioning droids
but how are they able to predict when
it's going to happen especially since
this malfunction ends up being triggered
by Mando himself holy inevitable Skynet
Uprising Batman that is a lot of droids
is having them loaded and unloading one
box at a time at a pace slower than
Michael Myers really the best way to
utilize them you have a whole Battalion
of Battle Droids that are less efficient
than one forklift in a pallet there are
a billion droids here and of course this
works on the third one that he kicks
was ridiculously and
uncharacteristically slow on the draw
here Mando gets knocked the [__] out and
she waits until the Droid runs past her
before drawing her pistol as if she knew
this episode was lagging and needed a
chase scene
Commando Ducks so that this box can kill
the people behind him instead of
scratching his precious armor keep going
of the impossibly perfect there's no way
he could have predicted when the Droid
would pass by the window and perfectly
self-definitrate himself to Victory
[__] that we just witnessed in this
stunt
I don't think they get many of our kind
here we got a sudden record stop and now
this line man this show is hitting all
the notes in its composition titled
entering a bar cliche stay where I can
see you oh come on Mando that's asking a
lot when you're talking about a helmet
that limits your field of view to about
12 degrees we can reason with droids the
behavior is programmed all they do is
reason bocatan could lead all of
Mandalore TV sins never have concerns
among my customers that we will be
replaced by what
humans I'm not sure if it's a compliment
or an insult that this robot thinks the
only species that could replace it are
humans also for some reason this droid's
calculations didn't factor in just how
lazy humans are if chant EPT is any
indication it's obvious that we're much
more scared of writing essays than we
are of the robot apocalypse we don't
want to be replaced we still have a lot
to contribute we get all of this World
building in a fascinating sneak peek
into the lives of this very specific
group of Droids on a planet we've never
seen before but when it comes to the
force we get [__] midichlorians great
yes I'm still sending the prequels
I'm sure the Droid will have the actual
answer but I'm willing to bet it's
exactly whatever the plot needs it to be
to make this side quest make
Sensei reprograms the Droids that drink
here it patches the programming as the
commands of the Mainframe change let me
get this straight Organics created
droids to do the work of Organics
because droids can be optimized and
don't need downtime but then those same
Organics created a Social bar situation
as a way to send software updates in the
form of in vibements why why isn't this
just downloaded I mean congrats on
creating a system of rolling out
software patches that's more convoluted
than Windows update but why this feels
like a needlessly analog filing system
for a robot these are the remains of the
latest malfunctioning Droid on this
episode of CSI the outer rim droids need
a coroner for some reason why wouldn't
they take the droids back to the ugnots
workshop the particles are definitely
present what are the chances that
they're still active
no less likely than them activating at
the perfect time to answer your question
I'd say these lasers conveniently yet
inexplicably Bank straight upwards
allowing Bo to get away unbifurcated
they're actually nanodroids how did
nanodroids get into the nepente oh boy I
can't wait for the answer to that
chain title says it didn't arrive on
plazier through Droid Acquisitions wait
a second it didn't go through Droid aqua
these Droids were ordered by an
individual our head of security
commissioner Hellgate belonging short of
this is that the malfunctioning droids
are caused by Nanobots and there's only
one possible person that could have
ordered them so how the [__] was
Hellgate ever expecting to get away with
this he didn't even try to throw DIN and
bow off the trail also isn't it cool
that the computer was programmed to do a
slow reveal of hellgate's image to match
the tension of the moment if I trigger
this fail save it will convert the
planet's stocks I'll work force back
into battle droids more like a fail
unsafe am I right okay let me get that
for you my lady using living things as
space bocce balls this planet is
unrecognizable since he arrived yeah but
how is his scheme to reprogram droids
gonna change that this is basically just
throwing a tantrum only this tantrum
results in more damage to the planet he
claims to love and banishment to a moon
as for now you must live in Exile on the
moon of paraquat we finally get
Christopher Lloyd in Star Wars and this
is what you do with him yeah banish him
to a Moon Star Trek made him a Klingon
and had Captain Kirk kill him I also
gives you both our highest honor the key
to plazier
do they always just have that thing on
hand didn't seem like they were
expecting them to turn up right now let
alone turn up with the mystery solved
then what's your play I'll know when I
get there for the record this is a
terrible play forgive me but reuniting a
civilization so you can reclaim your
home planet should require slightly more
prep than I'll do it on the night while
exploring Mandalore I was captured and
this blade was taken from me Bo Katan
rescued me and slayed my captor she
defeated the enemy that defeated me
would this blade then not belong to her
what the [__] were you saving this story
for you have the whole thing laid out
with all the justifications and you were
keeping that [__] in your pocket boat
could have just died fighting ax body
spray over there what the [__] man
though
and I won't
why me get satisfying
[Music]
a new life awaits
the chance to begin again in a golden
land of opportunity and Adventure why do
they have Imperial Droids on an
independent world because you'll love
them and they'll love you oh yes new
cities homes in the country your woman
at your side children playing at your
feet and overhead
fluttering in the breeze the flag of the
Federation
Ciao Bella
I don't know what that means